identify as black America is once again
having a heated discussion about race
and it's not because a cop got
trigger-happy it's because of this woman
Rachel Dolezal
in case you haven't heard Dolezal and
Africana Studies professor and civil
rights activist posed as a black woman
for almost a decade until her estranged
parents exposed her last week
our daughter is primarily German and
Czech and a European descent I'm into
controversy she resigned as president of
the n-double-a-cp chapter in Spokane
Washington her story has been confusing
and weirdly captivating they don't know
me there's a lot to be said so here's
some of it I felt very isolated with my
identity virtually my entire life a lot
of people have compared Rachel Dolezal
to Caitlyn Jenner just as Jenner always
felt she was a woman
Dolezal says she always felt she was
black so is Dolezal transracial over on
Twitter Sean said I applaud this brave
woman for being who she was born to be
hashtag trans Rachel but Darnell more
over at Mike comm takes issue with the
comparison saying transgender people
don't lie about their gender identities
yet Dolezal appears to have lied about
her racial identity she has said her
father's black lied about her race on
job forms and now her six hate crime
reports since 2009 are in question
she even unsuccessfully sued the
historically black Howard University in
2002 for discriminating against her
because she was white on top of that a
lot of folks are saying there's no such
thing as trans Rachel and when Dolezal
has done is straight up cultural
appropriation activist Kat Brooks told
me there are life experiences Dolezal
can never truly understand
I wish black people she just can't
identify past a black person
I remember being a little kid and trying
to understand how someone could hate me
because of the color of my skin and back
that's what she's been ritual never are
you a con artist
I don't think so Dolezal sympathizers
say at the end of the day she was an
advocate for civil rights so maybe we
shouldn't be so hard on her
one guy tweeted as a black man I have no
problem with Rachel Dolezal she probably
helped more brothers and sisters and
those criticizing her but Dave Chappelle
disagrees he told a group of students
there's a white lady posing as a black
lady there is not one thing that woman
accomplished that she couldn't have done
as a white woman there's no reason oh
and another thing
the n-double-a-cp says you don't have to
be black to work with them what many
find troubling is that the crazy
attention Dolezal story has received
overshadows other important stories
about race like what went down in the
couny case and be retweeted we know the
name Rachel Dolezal but not the makini
girl's name who was pushed down in her
bikini that's what's wrong here and sure
Dolezal has been an activist for racial
equality but so have many prominent
black women whose names you might not
know like alicia garza patrisse cullors
opal tometi the women who started black
lives matter oh and the girl from
McKinney Texas
her name is DeJoria Becton so a woman
with a shady story major family drama
and some apparently serious issues has
captivated us all but what do you think
about this controversy let us know